start off with Sierra and this our and
Sierra is in Utah hi Sierra how are you
I dunno how about you guys better than I
deserve
how can dr. John and I help I took out a
student loan my first year of school I'm
still currently in college and I didn't
qualify someone with in accrue interest
I now what qualifies the one that does
it doesn't accrue interest do you think
it'd be a good idea to pick out a loan
to cover my other love what are you
gonna finish school two years and how
much is the loan that you currently have
five thousand and what's the interest
rate I don't know I can tell you Sierra
I played the no quincies no take-backs
loop-d-loop game where I took one
student loan to pay off another student
loan and then paid off a car and and I
got so excited about the opportunity to
make this move and do that one and then
I ended up in a big big ol mess it's not
much money okay okay let's just say it's
5% interest we'll just make it up okay
so five times five is 25 right so that
means your interest on a five thousand
dollar loan is two hundred fifty dollars
a year okay for two years so the whole
discussion were having is five hundred
bucks which does not solve a five
thousand dollar problem so it helped me
I mean if you send me five hundred bucks
I'll take it it helps if I sent to you
you'd take it but it's I think it's more
important than fooling with that kind of
stuff that you just stay away from the
loans in general and that you guys lay
out a budget and a game plan where
you're able to cash flow the balance of
your education with no additional debt
the $250 doesn't concern me one way or
the other much here and it's good that
you're thinking about it but yeah you
really can't borrow your way out of debt
so it's okay to try it's okay to move it
if you
- but the problem is it kind of opens up
the gate of what John is saying and the
next time something comes along I'll try
that - and you just can't pay off your
debt anyway except pay off your debt you
can't steam your way through the end of
it and I know the interest rate if
you're gonna be a big kid and sign on
the dotted line and take money know what
you're getting into
yeah well it's good idea now that you're
there to know it - so get it out and
look at it after you get off the phone
and let's know what we've got what we're
dealing with going forward but that's
roughly what we're what we're talking
about here
you know John our I was looking at some
footage of the interviews that were done
and there was actually video portions
that we've not used yet that we were
looking at figuring out some things to
do with from the borrowed future podcast
series that we did and you were a big
part of that of course George Camel was
our host on that it's eight episodes if
you guys have not listened to it on the
Student Loan debacle that is out there
the this pandemic of student loans that
are there that were there before the
other pandemic got here and completely
out of control
the trillions of dollars jut mean with a
T and people getting you know the whole
system is just completely screwed up to
where we the people the citizens of the
United States are on the hook for a
program that Congress is so stupid that
it continues to leave in place 3 million
kids were going to student loan debt new
ones this year hmm this year and here's
how stupid it is we the people are so
bad at banking that we will loan an 18
year old $100,000 unsecured with no
explanation as to what he's going to do
with the money hmm
or she's gonna do with the money no
guidelines that it has to be spent on an
education that's actually freakin usable
with no no understanding of
might be paid back any other banker that
did that would be fired for incompetence
but you and I as taxpayers do that every
day we don't let that kid buy a gun we
don't let the kid buy a beer but here's
$100,000 go get them
make good decisions be smart is a
hundred grand be smart
we have also cost if we said you have
none of you don't have any so we've made
the laws to protect you from yourself
but here's $100,000 go get them it's
slow get them we know you we believe in
you you can do this I had this thought
about six months ago I was thinking like
other countries have you know a year of
social service or two years of military
prescription I don't know the right word
that make you be in the military for a
few years and we give we give you
$150,000 and say use this wisely why is
this lively be wise seventeen year old
be wise and we'll give you to you about
70s you're so to pay back ready
go get them Sikkim halfway through in a
degree from a through you can have a
beer Ivy League education and
left-handed puppetry go get them
yo get them yeah let's get up let's go
to a famous school and get a really dumb
degree sometimes oh no I'm just going
for a walk by myself I got to just shake
my head say man I hope they colonize
Mars soon you know but but what we need
to do is according to politicians we
need to forgive the student loans while
we're still making them but we need to
forgive them that's so intellectually
thinking skills of a politician that
says let's keep making these loans while
we forgive them America comes our start
bad so we should forgive them but we
need to make them because they're good
it's so intellectually dishonest it just
shows that they have no character in
Washington so here you go to listen to
this podcast it will it will blow your
mind how predatory Sallie Mae is how
predatory navient is how predatory we
the people are on our own kids
no wonder college prices shot through
the roof they have an unlimited supply
of money from stupid people this is
ridiculous you and me or the stupid
people not the kids by the way hmm
yeah it's just crazy so yeah we're we've
been calling on Congress to stop the
student loan program just stop it
completely yeah that'll be a bunch of
professors right after see a bunch of
broke cities a bunch of broke man oh man
we've created a quagmire for ourselves
yeah this is gonna be a little a little
bit of a barrel of fish hooks here baby
borrowed future check it out it's a
podcast series eight lessons or eight
episodes you don't want to miss it this
is the Dave Ramsey show